now to the Border crisis and an
important decision by the Supreme Court
that justices have decided for now to
keep in place a controversial policy
that allows border officials to quickly
expel many migrants seeking Asylum the
White House wants to end that pandemic
era policy Scott McFarland is outside
the Supreme Court Scott good morning
Adriana good morning to you the high
court says this title 42 program
implemented by former president Trump
must take in place for at least a few
more weeks because they say they'll hear
formal arguments on it in February under
title 42 the U.S has expelled more than
2 million migrants under a program that
began at the outset of the pandemic back
in March 2020 Republican Governors from
Southern border states have fought to
keep this policy in place and five of
the six conservative justices on the
Supreme Court at least for now have
sided with them though conservative
Justice Neil Gorsuch cited with the
three liberal justices going the other
way opposing the extension saying the
current border crisis is not a covet
crisis in a statement the White House
said title 42 is a public health measure
not an immigration enforcement measure
and should not be extended indefinitely
the Court's decision comes during a
state of emergency in El Paso Texas
where the number of migrants has
dramatic likely increased as the
temperatures have dramatically decreased
the Biden Administration has
acknowledged the eventual end of title
42 will likely lead to another surge of
migrants but they say the best way to
deal with that is for Congress to pass
comprehensive immigration reform
glad
all right to be continued Scott
McFarland for us thank you Scott